على مدار نحو 18 عاما هو طبعا عمره صباح
العربيه احنا من عمره تقريبا
استضافه او استضافه البرنامج شخصيات
مرموقه عربيه وعالميه تنوعت ما بين الفن
الرياضه والصحه والاعلام التقى بهم في
الاستوديو وخارجه ومن وسط ارشيفه الغني
اخترنا لكم بعضا من هذه المقابلات
باقي على حاله ما يقارب من العشرين عاما
وصباح العربيه يواكب الاحداث والفعاليات
العربيه والعالميه فهناك فنانون عالميون
مروا في مشوارنا الصباحي
مارتن وستنج وكات ستيفن وماريا كاروي
وجيني
ومنهم من فارقنا كوارث الجزائريه التي
اجرت اخر لقاءاتها في صباح العربيه قبل ان
ترحل ومنهم من ترك بصمه قد تكون ابديه في
عالم الغناء والموسيقى كبيبي كينج وشال
ازنبوه وملحم بركات واخرون كثر كانوا وما
زالوا اصدقاء البرنامج يوافينه بكل جديد
اصداراتهم وحفلاتهم حول العالم
القيصر او كاظم الساهر ونانسي عجرم والشاب
خالد وغيرهم الكثير
[موسيقى]
صباح العربيه كان وما زال سباقا في مجالات
عده ففي عالم الازياء والموضه كان اول
برنامج تلفزيوني صباحي يواكب عروض الازياء
الرجاليه العالميه من باريس وعواصم الموضه
الاوروبيه اما السينما فكانت حاضره بقوه
في صباح العربيه ضمن لقاءات حصريه مع
نجومها يسرا وحسن فهمي
وفرندون وجيمس كام وكيميو ريفز وايفامندز
ومادي ومنهم من فارقنا كالامريكي فليب
سايمر هوفمان الذي توفي في منزله في
مدينته نيويورك
صباح العربيه
بيسعدني كتير لانه ياما بحفلاتي بشوف
اشخاص
يعني مثل ما بيقولوا على هيفا بنبسط انه
فيها هاللوك
الطاغه على البنات والسيدات بسببي
كيف تحكمين على الكتاب الذي تختارينه
للقراءه تقرئين بضعه صفحات ومن ثم ان تمكن
منك هذا الكتاب تكملينه بالكامل بدون
انترنت وبدون تكنولوجيا اخذت معي جوال
اللي هو يسموه مدري ايش الشاف ده ولا اللي
هو وديت رقمه زوجتي ولابويا والمديره
الشركه عندي قلت لهم لا احد يكلمني الا
اذا في دم انا دايما بقول للشباب
يعني مفيش جوائز وما فيش حاجه بتدي
السعاده قد
الشفاء مريض او
اكتشاف حاجه جديده
بصراحه يعني محمد ودينا فعلا صباح العربيه
تحسها مدرسه ان كان من نوعيه الحوارات
واللقاءات يعني من فنانين لاعبين كره قدم
مغنيين مطربين كتاب
يعني ذكريات حلوه
وبتذكر فيه برضو ذكريات طريفه بتحصل مع
الضيوف انا بتذكر مره في ضيفين ما وصلوا
وهم الضيفين دكاتره بس في دكتور دكتور
اسنان في دكتور نفسي فبتعرفوا خلص اللايف
لايف يعني المباشر المباشر واحد من
الدكاتره دخل طبعا احنا فكرنا هو الدكتور
الاول طبعا الاسنان فقاعدين بنساله انه
نزيف بشكل جدا جدي يعني انه نزيف اللثه
عند ما يحدث ما هي الاعراض وكيف نتجنبها
واهوه كان قاعد على هالكرسي وانا بتذكر
يعني
بهالشكل هو هو بيقشر ليه كده من تحت من
تحت عشان الكاميرا ما تجيبوه اعملي وانا
مش عارفه ليه زعلان الاخ يعني بعدين قال
لي بعدين وطي صوته
ههه
على طول يعني غريبه هو موضوع اكتئاب ما
بعد الولاده هو ما يحدث بعد
الاكتئاب
ذكريات اللي ما بنساها
وبعدها يعني انه انقاذ لفنان تشكيلي بتعرف
انه نحن بصباح العربيه يعني الفقره خمس
دقائق ست دقائق فاذا بتستضيفي فنان تشكيلي
ولا بشكيلك ولا تشكيلك كل الاحوال
يعني
لوحتين ثلاث احكي عنهم جاي انا على الدوام
بلاقي ترك كبير
وعم بنزله لوحات لوحه ورا لوحه ورا لوحه
فانا بسال الشباب انه شو في ليش عم تنزله
لوحات فبقول للشاب سعر
صباح العربيه هذا طفل صباح العربيه طلعت
ولا جايب كانه كل معرضه 30 لوحه فرحت
حكيته انا انا انقذته يعني كانوا نازلين
صاروا سبع لوحات وباقي 23 لوحه بدهم
ينزلوا فقلت له انت رح تكون ضيفنا انا
محمد ابو المقدمه البرنامج فالبرنامج فقط
يكفي لوحتين او ثلاث لانه
هم الساعتين
[ضحك]
ضيوف فعلا ما بيبقوش حاسين قد ايه انه
الدقيقه على الهواء بتكون طويله
وفي طبعا غير طبعا الاوقات الضيوف اللي
بيجوا متاخرين يعني بفكروا ان احنا فاتحين
لانه هي القناه 24 ساعه لايف يعني عادي
الساعه يعني البرنامج بخلص 10 انا اوصل
عشره وربع